was there a time that you actually  thought the best option was to take your  own life  the very first time that I was suicidal  was when I was seven and I had this  fascination with death I have  experienced things that I have not  talked about and that I don't know if I  ever will talk about but at seven I knew  that if I were to take my own life that  the pain would end and so it's been this  thought where it came back when I was  bullied it came back several times when  I was struggling with with depression my  bipolar disorder  I turned to cutting and there was a  while there where my mom was afraid to  wake me up in the mornings because she  didn't know if she opened the door if I  would be alive or not  and because every time I cut it got  deeper and deeper